in november the small city of merit bc
awoke to this
the aftermath of an atmospheric river
that unleashed a torrent of rain
in a matter of hours the cold water
river that runs alongside the city
breached its banks washing away roads
bridges and homes
the force of the river grew so powerful
that it carved a new route through the
city a key water main burst and merit's
waste water treatment plant quickly
became inundated by the raging river
with no running water an evacuation
order went out for the entire city of
seven thousand people
when the rain finally stopped two weeks
later many residents returned to find
their homes devastated
a thick layer of silt coated everything
basements streets and even the city's
wastewater treatment plant located not
far from the river's banks
this was all flooded out the day of the
event
so during the event
our basement was filling up with water
from coming through our manholes and
running in through this chamber here and
it came up to the stair just level with
the wall there
the chief water operator here in merit
is kevin velak
he's been working alongside the public
works director to clean up the plant
the worst flood i've been through prior
to this was the flood in 2018 from the
nicola river
and in comparison
[Music]
it was nothing it was a mere trickle
compared to what we just went through
[Music]
there could be many merit bc's in canada
those flood events could occur in
southern saskatchewan or southern
ontario or new brunswick pretty much
anywhere blair feltmate studies how to
prepare communities for the more severe
weather of the future in industry lingo
it's called climate change adaptation
so adaptation is basically putting the
measures in place that make it such that
when the the big events occur the floods
the fires the hail storms wind storms
whatever it might be that the amount of
damage realized due to those events is
very much minimized because we've put
the measures in place to to keep the
damage in check climate change is
causing rising sea levels and more
intense storms making flooding the
biggest and most costly threat to canada
at risk is the country's most important
infrastructure
that's not just our roads and railways
it's electricity fuel water and food
supply the basic necessities of life
that
is mission critical to the fact that if
you're going to remain in the community
that stuff has to run if it doesn't run
you have to leave
when there's a flood municipalities and
provinces react
but what about preventative measures
like flood-proofing buildings and
essential services most of that falls on
local governments to plan and fund
the problem is those things come with a
steep price tag
linda brown is the mayor of merit and
she knows that most municipalities
especially smaller ones like hers can't
afford it
we're talking bridges
wastewater treatment plants those two
items alone are probably 30 40 million
so there's a whole lot of
dollars that we can't even fathom at
this point
whatever federal funding is available is
limited and competitive and that's led
to a patchwork of preparedness across
the country
the problem in canada on climate change
has been that up until just recent years
98 of discussion on the climate file has
focused on mitigating greenhouse gas
emissions which is the smart thing to do
and i'm fully in favor of that but we've
done so to the exclusion of talking
about adaptation
even in the absence of national
coordination a few cities have started
taking adaptation seriously
so there was a huge storm system that
moved through edmonton in 2004 and
caused massive flooding especially in
the southwest part of the city here
my parents were out of town and so i
rushed over here and
streets were flooded people were
actually canoeing out on the main road
behind my parents place
alberta's capital is prone to flooding
don iveson is the former mayor for years
he watched as his city was battered by
intense rainfall that caused flooding
along the north saskatchewan river as
well as in low-lying neighborhoods like
this one it was really surreal to come
back to the neighborhood that i grew up
in and see so much of it underwater but
it wasn't just that experience that made
iverson embark on a mission to transform
edmonton's flood preparedness
he was elected mayor in 2013 the same
year that calgary was hit by the worst
flood in the province's history we got
the clear message that the weather is
continuing to change the storms more
intense and that we needed as albertans
to all be thinking about this
ivanson worked with the city council and
the local utility ebcor they developed a
20-year plan for flood-proofing homes
and critical buildings and creating
green infrastructure to divert and store
water in the event of a flood so we're
standing in front of the new dry pond in
park allen here and so what it allows us
to do is uh take all the extra water
that falls uh in a severe storm event
about every 10 years or so and actually
store it in here you'll see from the
slope of the ground here that there's
quite a big bathtub
there is still a lot more work to do
one of edmonton's treatment plants that
provides water to nearly a third of
alberta's population
sits on a floodplain next to the river
ebcor is planning to build flood
barriers around the facility in the
coming years
it's not going to come cheap but it's
going to save us
uh you know billions of dollars in
insurance premiums and avoidable losses
as well as a lot of heartache and a lot
of disruption to families and businesses
for every one dollar invested in
adaptation we realize about three to
eight dollars in savings per 10-year
period in damage that now didn't occur
right now damage that does occur due to
flooding amounts to more than one
billion dollars every year by the end of
the century the cost for damage to homes
and buildings alone is projected to
surge to 14 billion dollars annually we
have aging municipal infrastructure that
breaks down when big storms hit we have
aging housing infrastructure and
increasingly so we're still
building in the wrong places as the
population increases we're building in
places that are vulnerable to flooding
in the wake of recent flooding
catastrophes there's a growing
recognition that national leadership and
a lot more money are needed to help
prepare for the extreme weather ahead
but in some flood-prone areas
preventative measures won't cut it
moving homes or entire communities away
from floodplains is the only solution
in merit mayor linda brown says that's
something they're now considering
we have people that are living in areas
now that are
a bigger flood plain than we could ever
imagine so we really have to talk about
moving some of them to drier land
we know the solutions the problem is
we're not mobilizing the solutions
nearly quickly enough therein lies the
problem for canada and if we don't do
that we are going to suffer
increasingly so due to extreme weather
events period there is no way to cheat
this system